given it was one of the country's worst
ever peacetime disasters it's far from
surprising that the fire at Grenville
Tower and West London in June 2017 that
killed 72 people
dominates the news agenda however this
is too grave a moment in our history to
allow fake news to take over and see the
tragedy hijacked for a wide range of
unfounded accusations until a few days
ago race campaigner Baroness Lawrence
mother of teenager Stephen Lawrence who
was murdered by racist gang in 1993 had
claimed firefighters would have acted
more boldly had most of the inhabitants
been white untrue and damaging insults
for which she has finally apologized
local MP Labour's Emma Dent code has
said the local council involved is
guilty of quits either racism or
snobbery
take your pick close quotes to the
London Fire Brigade and Kensington and
Chelsea Council have serious questions
to answer about command structure key
decisions on the night and decisions on
and inspection of refurbishments damn
right they do but for once can we not
rush to ill-informed judgment as so many
lives depend on it
[Music]
Nick you mentioned the local MP for the
area that grant will Terezin Emma's
ain't codes and I think it's important
to say that she made those comments
based on comment she says she heard
councillors make so it wasn't something
that she just decided she is the local
MP and she felt that there were
attitudes she'd witnessed that pointed
towards racism or snobbery
but Kensington and Chelsea have replied
to that and they say if these claims can
be substantiated we will of course
investigate them urgently but I hope
Emma would have reported them at the
time as both a local councillor and MP
it's good to see that they're taking
those allegations seriously and I'm a
little bit baffled really as to why in a
week when we've had some really serious
findings from the inquiry into ground
fault our you've chosen the one remark
that was made by Baroness Lawrence which
she quickly retracted and apologized for
and she had said that the individual
firefighters were motivated by racism
she's now apologized
for that but that's not really the
bigger issue here the bigger issue is
what were the institutional factors that
allowed 72 people to die
under those circumstances and the
findings we've had so far which are only
into this is only phase one everything
quiet how do looked at the bigger
context which is to come late acted
wrongly just lastly before it straight
up do you see any racial aspect to the
ground floor disaster at all I think
it's impossible to look at something on
this without taking race and class
together and I see a picture where
people were put in a building without
due regard for their well-being and
there's got to be some kind of assurance
in difference you know there was a
mother of five from Afghanistan
sixty-five partially sighted you can't
walk on a company place on I think it
was the 18th floor we don't know and you
know do you know what neck the lawyers
for the victims have had to fight for
institutional racism to even be included
in the terms of reference so I'm saying
let's do the work let's find out what
happened I'm not jumping to conclusions
but it's impossible to know that these
were people who were poor and some of
them were not kritis and these are not
people who have had the same privileges
in society as others I put something on
okay first of all the Baroness Lawrence
went to meet the fire brigade Union
represented fire and they they did issue
a statement actually which says that we
absolutely refute the claims made by
Baroness Doreen Lawrence that there was
any aspect of racism in our response to
the Granville tower fire or any other
incident every single one of the
firefighters and officers who responded
to the fire that night were fully
committed to rescuing as many people as
possible and put their own lives at risk
to do so I completely believe that I
don't think there's can be any argument
but however I think there's an
interesting point here this was an
unusual community we did a little
analysis I have a team that does data
analytics and we did a little analysis
on this what is interesting about this
was that there is no dominant group in
that tower in most communities there's a
sort of dominant community and if you're
the local authority or the police you
can go and talk to the Imam or you can
talk to the priest oh you can talk to a
local counselor I think something
interesting and worrying is
about Grenville they complained I think
with some justification they didn't have
a choice
a voice sorry yeah and that's I think
that is partly because this place felt
like if you like I don't use this term
pejoratively a Tower of Babel which
nobody quite knew who to talk to and
people didn't know each other and I
think that's an important element here
and just to say that's obviously your
research so that we just put that out
you live very close I live I live a few
hundred yards from Granville I was there
when the tower went up I've had taken my
kids to play dates in Granville Tower
and I go to the local sports center and
the local shops with people who live
lived in grandpa it's a key issue lt4
though I saw that morning hundreds of
firefighters risked their own lives to
try and save people in Granville Tower
Danny cotton said that the people who
sent the firefighters in said you could
you are risking your life you might lose
your life if you save these people who
are trapped in the tower they went in I
don't think we can criticize the
firefighters who worked throughout the
night Ingram for tower putting their own
lives at risk in this instance I don't
think racism was anything to do with the
institutional response or the emergency
service response to that tragedy and I'd
like to set that on record my people in
the tower and they're actually the
towers organisation was actually run by
a white man called Edward Daphne with
that Rachel but all I will say is
dealing with let's say a tower where
everybody speaks English if you are a
public service it's not quite it's not
the same as dealing with where there are
twenty thirty languages being spoken in
an emergency and I think we just need to
think about that someone let someone
know I've got two points to make my
first one is whatever happens going
forward we must make sure that lessons
are learned from what happened at
Grenfell that these people it was such a
tragedy and we need to make sure that
they did not die in vain and one of my
concerns is when you swap political and
governments things just get lost and get
dropped and we need to make sure that
whatever recommendations have come out
of this report they are implemented and
followed through so that this can never
ever happen again that's my first point
my second point is and I'm not someone
who gets outraged for outrage sake but I
am absolutely disgusted by the comments
that were made by someone that I
previously respected very much to even
suggest by Baroness Lawrence that if
these people were white they would have
been rescued I find that so offensive
and when you say I need to be clear
she apologized for the upset cause not
for the remarks not for the suggestions
it rises how we and we then hear from
Doreen Lawrence I've met at London Fire
and at London Fire Brigade Union I'm
reassured race played no part in their
response to the grand Fatah fire
learning about the conditions
firefighters faced that night has been
insightful apologies for any upset
caused I'm confident how valued equality
is
LFE and fbu bonus Lauren Lawrence is not
my greatest fan I can tell you that but
I have to say people make mistakes and
given what she has been through indeed
it's not it's it's not unforgivable this
is a distraction in my second part that
you started on the second pole which is
like the building regulations you know I
don't I think by raising race and class
people are getting distracted what I'm
saying is there is a structural problem
with the way we look after low-income
people and people in social housing
saying this is not a party political
issue successive governments have failed
people in public housing there are
chronic shortages and there were bad
decisions that were made and I have to
say Trevor I really disagree with you
and I think that kept arived able come
in it's pejorative this is actually
group that was organized that made
submissions about aluminum composite
material they did they were organized
there was a there was a campaign group
within they had the wherewithal to
select cladding material themselves
which was not used which major you're
talking about something quite different
this report was
do you get in the midst of an absolute
chaotic situation hundreds of people out
of a particular situation if you've ever
been near anything like that you will
know for example they need for instant
communication the capability to say to
people do this and they do that it's
absolutely central the only point I'm
making here is that this wasn't your
average vanilla setting where everybody
has the same culture same background
okay this is what this is what you have
to deal with in operations you can't
just assume that this is like every
other situation that's it's a simple
point I was making to Nick it's not
about the color of skin but in a
situation where there are people who
don't speak English who might not speak
English that's why they died they are in
a 22 block where the laddus community
that was surrounded with cladding that
was actually a source of fuel for the
fire the question was did they get them
out in time now that's not just a matter
anything oh yeah so the bigger issues
which I think are very fundamental
issues